перед тим як згадати Перші хвилини війни
Ну треба Ну з в першу чергу сказати що
країна до війни не була готова і тоді
зрозуміло як усіх були ці Перші хвилини
ви знаєте ще десь за рік до вторгнення
я
письмово уже звернувся до чинної влади
вони всім розповідали що у них є
головний план А це план міру який вони
планують забезпечити але на всякий
випадок у них є План Б тобто військового
такого активного захисту і в зв'язку з
тим що цей План Б ніхто де не бачив Я не
написав План Б і от видали його і там
детально розписав якими силами Росія
буде наступати по яким напрямкам з
півночі Сходу з півдня з території
Білорусі яка зброя у нас є яка зброя нам
потрібна нам потрібно створювати резерви
нам потрібно реально змістом наповнити
територіальну оборону нам потрібно
достатньо сильна система проти ну
захисту потужні які ми маємо їх треба
профінансувати і передати армії засоби
протитанкової боротьби
знаєте це нікого не зацікавило і ми
щодня наближались до цих кривавих подій
до цього вторгнення Я пам'ятаю десь за
тиждень до цього був у керівництва Києва
і на карті показував де надо робити
оборонні рубежі щоб затримати ворога
який може напасти на Київ ми сказали у
вас дуже поважаємо але без команди офісу
президента чи Генерального штабу ми
нічого копати не будемо тому що в нас
звинуватять паніки розцвітам ще в чомусь
і отак На жаль країна
входила в повномасштабні військові дії і
коли війна почулась
ви знаєте
паніка хаос
Я якраз був за межами Києва Київської
області і у мене була одна задача
добратись до Києва тому що всі шляхи
заблоковані всі виїзди переїзди
навіть військові які хотіли кудись
потрапити не могли це зробити тому що
комунікації і за ні організованості із
оцього хаосу все було заблоковано
але ви знаєте все-таки вдалося вже
вранці бути в нашій столиці я був на
військовому обліку в Службі безпеки
України Ну і думав що мабуть служба
должна одна із перших створювати бойові
загони які будуть зупиняти ворога на
підступах до Києва пішов там було
зачинено там вони щось говорили про
якусь евакуацію там
ніхто не хотів слухати що треба робити і
тоді ми зібрались наварських партійному
офісі і прийняли рішення
самі формувати батальйон територіальної
оборони буквально 3-4 години до нашого
батальйону уже записалась біля 500
чоловік питання в іншому а зброї то не
вистачає там 200-300 автоматів все вже
записуються люди А ми не можемо ми їх
озброїти
тоді Порошенко поїхав до Зеленського з
вимогою щоб поки збройні сили підтягнуть
свої арсенали то чого не було і зроблено
щоб відкрили склади Міністерства
внутрішніх справ що і було зроблено і
ми підтягнули достатню кількість
автоматів іншої зброї не було
але проблема їх тепер з набоями видавали
по два магазина
зрозуміло що по два буде не вистачати
почали видавати по одному магазину але
цього не вистачило тому кому не
вистачило набоїв тому давали траси Ну
щоб хоча би знаєте так лякав пугав це
перший день і в цих умовах Ми перші хто
більш-менш укомплектувався зрозуміло
шоломів ніхто не видавав броні жилетів
ніхто не видавав і не збирався видавати
і в цих умовах ми були готові
захищати Київ не було що центру який би
керував обороною Києва взагалі в зв'язку
з тим що ми по одній із перших
сформувались вже йшли бої
під гостомером Нас кинули зразу на
гостомельський напрямок саме там у нас і
були перші втрати першої 200 перший
поранені далі були
змагання
російської навали російської
Ірпінь і один з наших підрозділів
тримав бій під ночном де росіяни
намагалися робити переправу тобто в цих
умовах ви знаєте приходилось робити все
що можна тільки для того щоб захистити
і
В окопах які ми викопали і
треба було
логістично все забезпечити треба було
хоч якось
провести хоч якесь бойове злагодження
треба було провести хоч якесь Бойове
навчання тому у нас уже була група така
які мали бойовий досвід які хочуть вчили
людей як користуватися зброєю ключовим
стало мужність і система пожертвувати
українців
не розраховував російський генштаб на те
що в Україні буде достатньо героїв які
готові вмерти за свою країну от все вони
розраховував тільки вони не могли
зрозуміти це вони вважали що коли країна
так як реальності вона готувалася до
війни Ну давайте одне з найкращих потім
танкових засобів наступна за три роки до
війни не було закуплене для армії жодної
жодної було зупинено виробництво
боєприпасів це зокрема
[музика]
найбільш дефіцитних 152-го калібру бо
зупинив виробництва мін
недофінансовувалась ракетна програма
тобто безумовно російський штаб все це
знав і вважав що коли країна не буде
готова до війни то вони зможуть легко
зламати оборот але те що будуть сотні
тисяч героїв
здатних віддати своє життя але не
пропустити ворога оце вони не
розрахували ну і безумовно треба
подякувати нашим партнерам який
наполегливо попереджали нас про війну Ну
і це вже був на 14-й рік коли вони
боялись набої передати Україні коли ми
просили дайте хоч щось да і тоді казав
Ні ні ми не хочемо дратувати Путіна Да
ви якось там самі на дипломатичному
рівні або допомагати то тут була
принципова інша ситуація
буває реально допомога
наших стратегічних партнерів і за
рахунок цього Ми якраз змогли
компенсувати той дефіцит зброї
противотанкових засобів якій був в
країні перед початком цього масштабного
вторгнення це був початок 14-го року
військова агресія Росії і були реалії
того часу України не було боєздатної
армії не було сучасної зброї а країна
треба було захищати
з одного боку я звернувся до патріотів
від обрабаты пішли так як ми от 22-му
році так було в 14-му без броників без
шоломів з автоматами в спортивних
костюмах
проти російських танків але
я розумів що ми не зможемо
Таким чином відстоювати країну країні
було потрібно стратегічна зброя і в
першу чергу три бо компенсувати той
дефіцит зброї який був на той час
військово керівництво сказало що не
потужніша система
Ну десь на два тижні бою все далі нам
буде чим стріляти
на сході вже війна була треба було
Україну захищати і нам потрібно вона
буває своя українська альтернативація Я
зібрав у виробничників зібрав
конструкторів науковців і було доручення
терміново зробити свою ракету яка буде
краще ніж Російський аналог от Так
виникла програма вільхів і з нею
фактично почалась наша ракетна програма
потім була кривата ракета Нептун потім
була уже нова новий рівень верхівільха м
Яка мала більшу дальність знищення цілей
і високу точність
Ми почали посилювати наші противотанкові
ракетні засоби Але
для того щоб наприклад зробити сучасну
ракету необхідно мати тверду ракетне
паливо нам всі відмовились його постав
треба зробити своє виробництво а таке
виробництво є у десятка тут тільки країн
це високі технології тверде композитна
ракетне паливо виробляють тільки
провідні криниці і Україна сама зробити
свою базу свою виробництво другий етап
Ми почали робити навіть компоненти для
вас ними силовими компоненти для цього
впав тобто отаким чином вибудовувалася
наша
ракетна програма і так формувалась
формувався Базіс нашої реальної безпеки
ні на словах а саме От такі речі із
створюють безпеку України і реально не
залежність він на жаль на жаль
Це дійсно була колосальна проблема тому
що нові керівники йшли на вибори з
гаслами що вони забезпечать мир
достатньо швидко забезпечити припинити
стріляти і тому у них були пріоритети ми
переговори
зокрема з РФ вони намагались побачити
мір в очах цього покидька Путіна і на
жаль на жаль військовий пріоритети
оборонні пріоритети були відсунені на
другій план в результаті зупинили
виробництво боєприпасів
була зроблена До речі дуже гарно Себе
показала під час знищення ворога на
острові зміїним САУ Богдана але як ми
його зробили одну
[музика]
і вона вже навіть в 18-му році в параді
прийняла участь е-е програм була
зупинена ці галузі потужні хлопці які
працюють не гірше ніж ті які дають нам
сьогодні наші партнери вони не були
вироблені і ми почував війну з однією
Саул
так само зупинили у виробництво на жаль
не зрозуміло Чому навіть якщо
кримінальні справи якісь відкривали
виробництво боєприпасів І от зараз у нас
колосальний дефіцит е-е і снарядів і він
і негайно треба це робити відновлювати
це виробництво виробництво мін
виробництво гранат тобто все це було на
жаль незрозумілих причин фактично
заморожена припинила фінансувати
припинили включати до державного
замовлення
недофінсування постійно і запізнення
фінансуванням тої самої ракетної
програми і тому на початок вторгнення у
нас були буквально одиниці ракет які
дуже швидко використовувати так дійсно
дві ракети Нептуна да відправили на дно
Флагман російського крейсер Москва були
інші е-е
варіанти ви його використання ви ж
розумієте Даже коли ми говоримо про той
самий Нептун уже до 20-го року ми
повинні були мати не тільки мобільні
комплекси крилатих ракет А ми повинні
були мати комплекси повітряного
морського базування ці програми також
були зупинені е-е у нас одна із
колосальних проблем це протиповітряна
оборона
Ми почали розробляти
уже фактично все було готове для
випробувань і виробництва
зенітна ракетни комплекс середньої
дальності Ця програма також була
зупинена і ви ж розумієте що багато
втрат які ми несемо за того що
росіяни активно використовують
використовують свої ракети своїх літаків
це якраз проблема нашої слабкості
протиповітряної оборони А це могло бути
зовсім інакше Мій досвід мої знання
керівництво країни не потрібні
і тому
я пішов з першого дня
воювати
простим піхотним офіцером після того як
вже був організована оборона Києва після
того як ворог був розбитий на підступах
до столиці і викинути за межі Київської
області
наш підрозділ перекинули на південь
країн А ви знаєте що саме на півдні на
сході і зараз фактично вирішується доля
цієї війни і доля нашої Батьківщини ви
знаєте там е-е жарко і в прямому і
непрямого сенсі цього слова від дуже
запеклі бої Ми захищали Миколая потім
присунулись вперед
і наша передові позиції зараз приходять
по Херсонській області і намагаємось
крок за кроком просуватись вперед але це
достатньо
важко тому що для того щоб забезпечити
повноцінний наступ не потрібно його
реклама да по телебаченню не потрібно
його реклама в засобах масової
інформації а потрібно перевага в першу
чергу в засобах враження І
потрібно посилення в пройній техніці Да
і тоді дійсно це може бути достатньо
ефективно і швидко ворог використовує
достатньо си потенціал артилерії своїх
ракетних військ і
Миколаїв постійно під обстрілом постійно
під обстріл нашої позиції
півгодини до нашої зони зустрічі ще два
бойкобратіма з другої роти загинули
захищаючи нашу позиції
[музика]
це важко але
незважаючи на всі проблеми Я сподіваюсь
що
перевага в нас в засобах враження в
першу чергу говорить і
ми зможемо звільнити спочатку правий
берег а потім вже перейти на ліву берег
це
достатньо ви знаєте
важке Випробування я можу не зовсім
молода людина хоча
сподіваюсь тримати форму Да але Повірте
коли 40 градусів повітря ти в збройні
жреті в повний боевой выкладки з
боєкомплектом і треба на передовой
пересувати стільки бігом це так
важкувато серце і звертає іноді вискакує
але нічого тримаємось у нас багато людей
які вміють красиво говорити Да але на
війні треба красиво воювати да І тому ми
все витримуємо і все одно переможемо
як би нам важко не було чи під час
революції першої другої чи під час війни
на початку 14-му році чи зараз я завжди
був переконаний в нашій перемозі був і
більш складні і більш важкі часи але
Віра тримає нас і саме це відрізняє нас
від
російської армії від цих Харків вони
робили вони найманці
Вони не розуміють
що вони тут шукають в цій країні
у них нема мотивації
віддавати своє життя за цю безглузду
безумну операцію
якої вони називають
війну проти України а українці готові
вмирати за свою країну І от в цьому нашу
перевага в цьому наша сила і саме тому
ми їх переможемо